early in the morning Israeli forces
arrive at a refugee camp in Janine
a bulldozer leads the way
Israeli Army troops fire an anti-tank
weapon a tactic called the pressure
cooker designed to get people inside the
building to flee leaving this home in
Flames then begins an hours-long armed
confrontation that leaves dozens wounded
some dead this mobile phone video
appears to capture the moment one gunman
is killed
at a nursery nearby the sound of gunfire
sends children scrambling the target of
the raid was the home of relatives of
Rod qasim a gunman who killed three
Israelis and injured several more in
April in a bar in Tel Aviv he eluded
Israeli forces for hours before they
finally fatally shot him this video
shows Israeli forces drilling holes for
explosives in his home in September then
demolishing it with a blast the Israeli
Army says on Wednesday it was looking
for two gunmen suspected of carrying out
recent shooting attacks one of them was
qasim's brother Abdul Rahman
farihazam has now lost a second son Rod
cosm's brother Abbott died in the attack
on Wednesday
they demolished our house but those are
only bricks they are not going to
destroy our determination they killed my
sons but they are not dead they are
alive in heaven we believe in God and
accept his will the raid follows an
increase in armed Palestinian attacks on
Israeli Targets in the occupied West
Bank especially in the northern cities
of Janine and Nobles the Palestinian
Authority condemned the rape with prime
minister Muhammad shtaya saying
Palestinian blood has become a ticket in
the upcoming Israeli elections some
Israeli leaders say the Palestinian
Authority appears to be losing control
on the West Bank Palestinian leaders say
the rise in attacks on Israeli forces is
due to frustration over the lack of a
peace process the Oslo Accords that
promised Palestinians their own State
nearly 30 years ago never created one
and the generation that's grown up since
then is growing in patient
hours after the attack the funerals were
underway as is required under Islamic
tradition but they are only likely to
increase Rising tensions on the West
Bank John hendron Al Jazeera romala